there are 1.3 million Americans who are  rationing their insulin because of the  high costs understand that on so many  issues Republicans and Democrats aren't  very different and when that's the case  I tell you and I call it out on this  issue of lowering the price of insulin  it has been Democrats who have been  fighting for it and Republicans who have  been fighting against it and it's not  some abstract problem there are quite  literally people who are using less  insulin than they should be per medical  recommendations because of the price  this is one of the richest countries in  the world it is a travesty that this is  going on and there is one party that is  primarily to blame for it you know who  it is